[Music]
the movie begins in 1897 when the indian
troops were governed by the colonizing
british government on the border between
british-held indian territory and
afghanistan lies the ghoulistan fort in
the fort the brave sikh regiment of the
british indian army is posted the
protagonist of the film is ishar singh a
hevaldar of the regiment one afternoon
ishar and his fellow soldiers are
patrolling the border when they hear a
woman's cry on the other side of the
border a group of afghan tribesmen is
about to kill a married woman because
she refuses to accept her husband who
has been chosen by her family without
her consent they are led by a
self-proclaimed prophet saidullah who
takes the responsibility to kill the
poor woman ishar wants to intervene but
a higher british officer lawrence orders
him to stay put since the commotion is
taking place on the other side of the
border where their rules don't work the
woman is seconds away from being
beheaded when her supposed husband is
shot and killed ishar has defied direct
orders from his superior to save her he
runs to the other side and continues
killing everyone that comes forward to
stop him the afghan woman is asked to
run away and anyone who tries to stop
her is killed eventually the men manage
to catch ishar and try to take off his
turban to insult him his fellow sikhs
follow his lead and attack the enemies
when it comes to the pride they hold in
their turban in the end the afghans are
defeated and saidula is chased away but
lieutenant lawrence is enraged by the
audacity of the indian troops he is
extremely racist to anyone who isn't
british and thinks all indians are
cowards he writes a strong report
informing his commanding officer of
ishar's disobedience in the following
scene ishar and his comrade gulabo are
chatting outside the fort when all of a
sudden someone shoots galabo on his
shoulder the enraged afghan troops have
attacked the fort because of what ishar
did yesterday the indian troop gets in
the position ready to fight as a
shootout ensues ishar climbs down the
fort and into the enemy's territory he
then uses an explosive to attack them
when they least expect it because of his
smart strategy the enemy has to retreat
the commanding officer praises him for
his bravery but cannot let him off the
hook for disobeying an order hence he is
transferred to a neighboring fort
saragari no one wants to work in
sarigari fort because it lies between
two bigger forts and is mostly used as a
post office to transfer messages between
them no action ever happens in saragarhi
hence only 21 soldiers including ishar
are assigned to it before he leaves for
the posting lawrence calls ishar and
humiliates him calling him a slave to
the british government ishar is made to
apologize and his cowardice is blamed on
the indian soil however he refrains from
talking back in order to not be
reprimanded further the next day ishar
sets off for the new fort on the way the
afghan woman he saved approaches him
they do not understand each other's
language but ishar figures out that she
is thanking him for saving her life he
accepts a sweet dessert from her before
continuing the journey upon reaching the
fort he is welcomed by corporal lao and
his assistant gurmak singh ishar is
shocked at how young gurmak is as he is
only 19 years old and knows more english
than anyone else in the fort since ishar
arrived quicker than everyone else
expected he finds the rest of the troops
watching two roosters fight no one is in
their uniforms or is following the rules
a soldier must abide by on seeing ishar
they stand in a line but fail to impress
him he berates the troop for being a
shame to the entire sikh community as
punishment they are asked to wrestle
each other while the roosters watch them
and are not allowed to stop until the
animals say so one of the soldiers
inquires how a rooster will speak and is
made to run around the fort for asking a
stupid question ishar then keeps lal to
oversee the punishment the soldiers
wrestle for the rest of the day while
one of them continues making rounds of
the fort hours later ishar finds them
joking around and singing when asked why
they stopped lal claims that the
roosters asked them to they were making
a noise that sounded like cook hence the
troop thought they were british roosters
who wanted to be cooked and did what the
animals said ishar holds his laugh and
punishes lao for not doing his duty
properly he is asked to starve for the
next week his fellow soldiers take a
stand and claim that they will also be
punished alongside lal since he is their
comrade ishar allows it and continues
torturing the group for the next two
days during this time we find out that
all 20 of the soldiers have family back
home who they're hoping to see soon one
man's father has worn the same shoes his
whole life so he is getting a pair of
shoes ready to give to him as a gift
another man is a father himself whose
wife just sent him a letter with the
handprints of his month-old daughter
similarly there are people who have been
oppressed because of their social class
and the ones who miss their mothers
dearly after two whole days of not
eating anything the soldiers start to
complain ishar feels bad for them and
allows them to end the punishment early
however a soldier named chanda
retaliates saying that they do not need
pity from ishar he doesn't like ishar
and thinks he is a servant to the
british the cook named dad reveals that
ishar also hasn't eaten for the past two
days and asks the soldiers to decide
what they want to do accordingly when
they ask ishar why he punished himself
for their mistake he replies that he
wouldn't dare to eat when his comrades
are starving he manages to win their
hearts with the comment and they feast
together in the meantime saidullah the
afghani man who wanted to kill the woman
earlier arranges a meeting with the
leaders of three afghan tribes till now
they have been fighting against the
british government on their own but if
they continue the battle as a team they
will have a higher chance to win the
tribe leaders agree and start devising
an attack they plan to take over all
three forts on the same day starting
with the one with ishar since it is the
easiest to conquer saidullah predicts
that they will take less than two hours
to kill the 21 soldiers because their
army consists of around 10 000 people
after defeating ishar's troops they will
make their way toward the other two
forts and conquer them as well
somewhere else ishar is told that their
informant from a nearby afghan village
has been missing for the past two weeks
assuming that something is wrong ishar
and lal go to the said village to
investigate they find the village filled
with women children and elders but no
young men moreover the responsibility to
build a mosque is also upon the elderly
and women of the village on returning to
the fort that day ishar reveals that he
wants to help the village build the
mosque most soldiers are against it
since their religion doesn't align with
islam still ishar goes on his own and
starts helping the villagers at midday a
kid is almost killed under a falling
ceiling ishar saves him and is in turn
saved by his comrades who have come to
help by the end of a few days they
complete the mosque and an old woman
feeds them one almond each one of the
soldiers keeps the almond as something
valuable because it reminds him of his
mother and because let's face it that's
not going to do [ __ ] for his hunger in
the following scene the soldiers are in
their posts when they get a message from
the neighboring fort asking them to stay
alert because the afghan troop is
planning to land an attack on them ishar
looks at the faraway mountain through
his monocular but sees no one just when
they think it is a false alarm the sound
of war drums echoes in their ears one
man followed by a hundred then thousands
come into view the crowd makes way for
sidula who has caught the woman ishar
once saved to declare the initiation of
war zydula beheads her and the crowd
erupts into cheers then ishar receives a
letter from his superiors through the
lamp post he gathers the soldiers and
tells them that they have been ordered
to retreat and run for their lives a
loud laugh interrupts ishar as the
soldier famously known for never smiling
bursts out in front of everyone he and
the rest of the soldiers think it is
funny that the british believe the sikhs
will run away like cowards ishar
understands their sentiment but asks
them to give it another thought because
their death is confirmed if they choose
to fight chanda who never liked ishar
thinks he is trying to shake their
spirit and is afraid to get into the
battlefield as a reply ishar goes into a
room and comes out wearing a saffron
turban symbolizing courage he plays the
war drum and kills the first enemy to
start the battle everyone gets ready in
their posts except the 19 year old
gurmak who seems confused he asks ishar
why he lied to the troop saying that the
superiors wanted them to run away when
the actual orders were to fight ishar
reveals that by giving the soldiers a
choice it is proven that they are not
cowards like lawrence once said then he
orders the cook to serve water to
everyone injured even the enemies the
shootout begins and the sound of
continuous gunshots follows an explosive
is thrown toward the sikh's soldiers
which causes a man to fall off the fort
before he is killed a comrade goes to
his aid they are being aimed at by the
sharpest shooter of the enemy hiding
behind a stone before he gets to shoot
them ishar arrives and does the same to
him when they reach inside safely ishar
scolds gurmak for not shooting the man
who threw the explosive gurmak replies
that he has never killed anyone and is
scared of the enemy troop without
wasting any more time ishar assigns him
to the lamppost duty from where he has
to continuously send updates to the
other forts when ishar gets back to his
spot the enemy troops start to retreat
saidullah and the tribe leaders come
forward with a white flag asking to talk
to him the leaders of both parties meet
and ishar instantly recognizes saidullah
he inquires if saidullah is willing to
put his life at risk or is he just good
at killing helpless women while the
tribe leaders are calm saidullah burns
in rage promising to step on ishar's
turban later that day two sikh soldiers
hand over two afghan prisoners who were
arrested earlier ishar claims that they
don't kill people who surrender however
it turns out that the prisoners are bait
as soon as a cloth is removed from their
faces an explosion occurs that kills
several afghan soldiers the fight
continues but by now the rivals have
reached the outer walls of the fort
another soldier dies of a gunshot while
the afghans start banging on the fort's
door three soldiers are sent to stop the
door from being broken meanwhile ishar
focuses on the sharpshooter who killed
the soldier he straps his monocle to the
rifle to get a better aim and shoots the
man dead with a single shot downstairs
the soldiers wait until the troops run
out of bullets and land their attack
they manage to kill many but more
enemies keep on coming suddenly a
soldier named bola is shot during the
last minute of his life he says that he
is happy because death makes everyone
equal and he is no longer inferior to
the upper castle the others try to stop
his bleeding and a fellow soldier even
offers his turban to put over the wound
but bola dies in the end soon they run
out of bullets and think of another
tactic to stop the rivals they open the
door making it seem like they have given
up before attacking the troop outside
even though they are a few fighting
against a hundred they display a great
show of bravery and kill as many people
as they can with his last breath lal
asks the only surviving soldier to run
inside and close the door he does as
told but is heavily injured before dying
he sits beside bola's dead body and
recites the joke that he used to hate
outside lao dies while looking at the
picture of his daughter's handprint in
the meantime several dead bodies have
piled up beneath the wall the afghans
used the bodies and ropes to climb up
the fort the first few men are defeated
but then more start climbing and killing
ultimately the last comrade also dies
when he pushes himself and a bunch of
afghans off the wall he also detonates
an explosive killing many right before
his death now only ishar gurmukh and
chanda are left out of the 21 soldiers
ishar orders them to stay upstairs in
the lamp post while he fights the entire
army on his own the enemy finally gets
into the fort and is welcomed by the
leader the first person to attack him is
sliced through his stomach which sends
the others behind him into a frenzy
ishar is surrounded but he fights like a
beast and stands in the battleground for
several minutes against a horde of
enemies suddenly he stops when he sees
the man he is about to kill is a young
boy someone shoots him in the shoulder
which weakens him but not his spirit
chanda also joins him in the fight and
is killed with several knives in his
body winishar has no weapons he fights
with stones but is ultimately subsided
the boy who he didn't kill earlier is
the one who stabs him last saidullah
arrives inside the fort and kills the
poor cook even though he is feeding
water to the afghan troops then he tries
to take off ishar's turban with all his
remaining strength he stabs saidullah in
the throat and kills him it is about to
get dark and the other forts have
probably called for backup by now the
soldiers were able to complete the
mission even after their deaths a tribe
leader orders everyone to stay away from
ishar's turban impressed by his bravery
he leaves but the second leader still
wishes to hear a sikh cry in pain they
set fire to the lamppost waiting for the
only surviving member germac to cry
instead the brave teenager runs outside
shouting a war cry of the sikhs he then
grabs the leader and triggers the
grenades attached to his body resulting
in a huge explosion and the deaths of
many in the end the surviving afghans
loot the fort and set it on fire after
that the british parliament honors the
martyrs with the british order of merit
the highest award an indian soldier
could receive two gerdwaras are built in
the memory of the brave soldiers which
are still visited by many tourists every
year
i've been complaining about a slow
internet connection all week this kind
of story really helps put things in
perspective subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching